Này em mới thường chính, u cuối nào và ngà điều thung bảo đã trải qua các nửa tình công bằng thứ bị bài thung người lại ua vê nhằm vào nhiều khu vực.
Về việc ua quay nà, thung quân nước này thung bảo đã phát hiện tổng công sau trám buơi chính thung tị tình công, vô 5.5 mì chính ua vê, tám tên lợi đả đạo và 5.2 tên lửa hành trình.
Tức lượng phòng không bàn hạn 5.5 mì 2 ua vê, 2 tên lợi đả đạo và 2 mì chính tên lợi hành trình.
Các tiêm tự em sảo tham chiến đất lình giá là đáng hoạt động hiệu qua cho thấy khả năng tắt chiến của Thì Tài,
gió phương tài viện trở theo tổng thung ua quay nà vô đồ đi mê dây khi các hủ tập đất đự nhiệm tạo chính khu vực bảo vệ gồm cả tu đốt kẻ,
nhằm vào các tơ sở hạt tăng khu vân cư và vệ nghiệp vụ tấn công khiến ít nhất bằng người thịt mạng và hành trục người bị thương.
Đồng thời gai hư hả nhiều nhà cư và phương tiệt.
Chong khi đó phía bộ của phòng ngà trên bố, lực lượng nước này đã đảy lụi các đường tấn công ua tạng 2 tình vô ngô gó gác và rút tốt.
Đồng thời khẳng định hệ thông phòng không đã phát hiện và bản hạm một chăm buồn mấy chiến qua vê.
Giờ chức ngà khi nhận một người bị thương, tạng sẽ ra tốt.